Майже дві сотні жертв і мільярдні збитки від повені.
Німці досі шоковані, як таке могло статися у 21-ому столітті та ще й у такій розвинутій та, здавалося б, до всього заздалегідь готовій країні.
Чи можна було запобігти руйнівній катастрофі?
Чи були жителі завчасно попереджені про небезпеку затоплення?
Як вказують метеорологи, європейська система раннього попередження про небезпечні повені,
яку створили у 2002 році після затоплень на Ельбі та Дунаї, ще за чотири дні до катастрофи оповістила німецьку владу.
Одна з розробниць цієї системи Ганна Клок впевнена, що жертв можна було уникнути.
Я бачила цю інформацію ще на початку тижня і ситуація вже тоді виглядала досить серйозно, очікувалася сильна повінь.
Тож мене вразили кількість смертей і руйнувань, тому що, з моєї точки зору, це лихо можна було передбачити.
Тож щось пішло не так із системою сповіщення населення.
Водночас глава Федерального агентства допомоги при стихійних лихах Армін Шустер запевняє, що перебоїв у системі не було.
Наша система попередження спрацювала в кожному окремому випадку.
Німецька метеослужба, центри для боротьби з повенями і місцева влада активно використовували їх.
150 сигналів попередження були передані через нашу систему.
Деякі з цих повідомлень відправлялися через спеціальні мобільні додатки.
Але вони були далеко не в усіх мешканців і працювали не завжди справно.
Жителі Ерфтштадта, де внаслідок зсуву під землю пішов цілий район міста,
спершу отримали повідомлення про те, що їм слід залишатися у своїх будинках.
Наступного дня прийшла інформація, що греблю неподалік може прорвати.
Натомість жителі регіону Арвайлер, де найбільша кількість жертв - понад сто осіб, жодних повідомлень не отримали взагалі.
Тим не менше про негоду попереджали по радіо і телебаченню.
А в деяких місцях - і з допомогою ось таких сирен, які залишилися ще з часів холодної війни.
Але й вони впоралися із завданням не скрізь.
Вони включають ці сирени кожну першу суботу місяця, але коли щось дійсно трапляється - ні. Я цього не розумію.
Нині у Німеччині закликають встановити більше таких сирен або модернізувати старі,
а також оповіщати жителів за допомогою СМС в разі подібних катастроф у майбутньому.
У Німеччині, як і в багатьох інших країнах, не існує єдиного загальнонаціонального підходу до ризиків повеней.
Для різних сценаріїв необхідні різні плани реагування.
Є повені, спричинені дощами, шторми на узбережжях та сезонні паводки.
Усі ці можливі сценарії мають різні вимоги і
в місцевих адміністраціях маленьких селищ часто просто недостатньо ресурсів, щоб завжди правильно реагувати.
Крім того, є питання до норм евакуації, хоча ці норми для кожного конкретного випадку важко передбачити.
Приміром, в одному із селищ у землі Рейнланд-Пфальц дванадцятеро осіб потонули у закладі з догляду за людьми з розумовими вадами.
Евакуація проводилася з територій, що знаходяться в межах 50 метрів праворуч і ліворуч від річки Ар.
А будинок для людей з розумовими вадами був розташований приблизно за 200 метрів від води.
Коли ситуація різко погіршилася вночі, рятувальники вже не змогли подбати про цих людей.
Тож багато хто тепер каже, що краще бути надмірно обережним і у випадку сумніву
радше ухвалювати рішення про евакуацію людей, ніж потім не встигнути взагалі.
Дбати про власну безпеку та безпеку своїх осель - це також обов’язок усіх, хто мешкає в подібних регіонах.
Повені тут відбувається регулярно, і ніколи не варто думати, що якщо раніше не було надто високої води, то і цього разу пронесе.
Багато місцевих під час нинішньої зливи просто неправильно оцінили небезпеку і недостатньо серйозно поставилися до попереджень.
У нас проїжджала пожежна машина, щось оголошували в гучномовець, але не було чути.
Я запитала в сусідів: вони сказали, що потрібно відключити електрику, що вода прибуває.
Але ніхто не очікував, що води в будинку буде більше двох метрів.
Були попередження про сильний дощ і так далі.
Але деякі з них були невірними: наприклад, про другу повінь.
Ми всі піднялися на пагорб, але нічого не було.
Експерти радять не лише покладатися на місцеву владу і рятувальників,
а й самостійно готуватися і заздалегідь подбати про запаси їжі, медикаменти та інші товари першої необхідності.
Адже через зміну клімату експерти застерігають, що подібні катастрофи можуть траплятися частіше.
Звинувачувати лише місцеву владу "заднім числом" у системному провалі, означає недооцінює силу самої природи.
Один кубічний метр води важить цілу тонну і потужні потоки води та бруду здатні змітати все на своєму шляху.
Метеорологи можуть передбачити регіон, де мають статися опади, але не можуть назвати точне місце, і тим більше -
визначити точний обсяг води, який тут впаде.
До того ж, руйнівною силою володіє якраз та маса, яку потоки води несуть з собою.
Вирвані дерева та інші об'єкти - аж до автомобілів, як це було в Арвайлері та інших затоплених містах,
врізаючись на величезній швидкості, таранять і руйнують стіни будівель.
Потоки набувають колосальної сили.
Склад ґрунту, тобто його здатність вбирати воду, також може мати вирішальне значення під час повені.
Глиняний ґрунт, наприклад, може увібрати менше води, ніж піщаний.
А ґрунт з великим вмістом торфу має ще більшу здатність вбирати воду.
Тож шукати винних у цій катастрофі, на думку деяких експертів, це марна справа.
Адже є сильніші за людей сили природи, які вражають так швидко і несподівано, що немає жодних систем,
здатних завчасно спрогнозувати їхню руйнівну силу.
Навіть за допомогою найкращої ​​техніки та передових технологій.